Okay, so the way you can think about this question is by looking at the first
message and why it makes sense to have two bits per symbol. So you can be
present this bit pattern in a tree. So when a new bit comes in, it can be
either 0 or a 1. If it's a 0, the next
symbol can be another 0 or it can be 1. The same case here, so if there are
two 0s, it is an A, if it is a 0 followed by 1, it is a B, if it is a 1 followed
by 0, it is a C, if it is a 1 followed by 1, it is a D. So that
is why you need to ask two questions to reach either
of these symbols. What happens in this new language? So in
the this new language, it occurs 50% of the time. So
we can directly ask if it is A or not A.
So that's represent that has 0 or 1, and let A be
0. So now we got our A as just a 0. Now if we go on the one
branch we can again ask, if it was a 0 or a 1. Now observe that
D occurs twice as frequently as B or C. So,
in this case we can be present D here using 1, 0 and
then B or C can occur on this branch
but both cannot occur at the same place, so we
need to differentiate between them using another symbol. So
let's do that using 0 and 1 again. So this
can be B and this can be C. So B is basically 1, 1, 0 and C will be
1, 1, 1. Now have we actually saved any
bits per symbol, have we saved the number of questions
we asked? Yes because A occurs more frequently and I needed to ask only one
question. But what is the exact number of questions we are to ask for symbols?